yes and congratulations on that victory
you've won a few games in a row is it
three in a row now three in a row so
you're pulling a mini carissa
but as you know she has won the
tournament with her performance but this
is a big win for you that guarantees you
at least a tie for third no matter what
happens how do you feel about the way
the game transpired
actually it's good i guess and overall
i played a good tournament and good game
so far
so
[Music]
i mean we came here to win the
tournament of course that's why i'm
i'm not that happy with my performance
because i know that i could do much
better according to positions as well so
it's still fine i'm glad
that i could
at least win a couple of games in the
end
your position in the opening she seemed
to just come after you with some
original play with c3 you started with
knight d7 in the opening and then she
played this idea with c3 and took on d5
with the queen instead of taking with
the knight on c3 were you surprised at
that moment the way she was playing c3
was surprising and i didn't check this
line with c3 and
during the game i realized oh my god i
missed this move like i didn't check it
but
in general black should be fine i didn't
see any problems maybe for me it would
be a little bit better to play
knight
b d
db8 instead of knight c5 i would just be
pun up there without like
um
any counter play i guess but
the engine loves your move knight c5 but
my position would be so passive that's
why i really didn't want to go there
yeah
yeah your engine the engine loves knight
c5 they think but things after knight c5
that position it was very hard to play
with black i guess i had to be very very
precise luckily she didn't make the best
moves i guess
all these moves the engine loves by the
way your retreating moves were perfect
and precise as you mentioned
it was here you you had a night night
before g4 or a4 but i just wanted to uh
exchange all the rooks that's why i put
rook to simon first i thought okay she's
gonna play four and i'm playing id a4 i
thought this version is better but then
i realized that she has to take on this
summon and play rook b1
maybe it would be a little bit better
for her okay the position is worse but
still
better attempts you're saying yeah and
maybe she could take actually earlier on
c6
when i played castle she could take on
c6 and then uh btx c6 queen c6 rook b8
and queen c2
instead of uh
after castle and i think this is the
line that you mentioned
instead of knight to c3 on c6 i don't
know
wait oh yeah this position
she could she could definitely but it's
still better for black yeah it's still
better i have two bishops but i thought
maybe it's better for her to play this
position
but she was trying to like win uh no
matter what that's why she played this
kind of opening and she didn't like the
idea of exchanging some pieces i guess
that's
it was strange the way she played when
she took on d5 for sure instead of
playing with with knight takes on c3
and
psychologically for her it was difficult
because she'd been leading the
tournament for so long and suddenly now
she was on her back foot she was
i don't think she was leading you don't
think she was leading you want to do
commentary for us
no carissa was leading no
no katarina was leading the tournament
all the way through
through seven rounds it's when she got
passed by carissa only then she was plus
three
with no losses i mean she hasn't played
me and karissa and crush at that point
right exactly she ended up having a
tough role at the very finish and that's
what has cost her
so you basically have
uh not the victory to play for another
top result how do you approach this last
game
i'm just gonna do my best and that's all
as usual i really enjoy playing and it's
an amazing opportunity because i have
school
and i don't have that much time to play
chess so i have been enjoying whole
tournaments and
i hope that i will play a good game
tomorrow as well all right well good
luck with that one we'll see you
tomorrow thank you very good luck
congratulations